on va démarrer par dylan et après kelly
le fera d'accord attention dylan tu vas
être chronométrée est ce que tu connais
parcours dylan tu dois passer la tu
passe en dessous tac tac tac tac tac tu
vas là tu vas encore en dessous la
poutre et après tu passe là bas comme on
dit là bas ce qui est un aventurier
tatts enlève tout ce que tu veux sauf
ton slip d'accord merci mon dieu était
beau et beaucoup d'entre eux sont celles
bien attention mondiale
le tpr est quoi 2
il est très fort
tout cela
tu vas
[Musique]
très forte dylan j'ai presque envie de
se dire est ce qu'on a besoin d'eux on
va voir ce que ça donne
attention attention je crois toujours à
moi la belle affaire 13 secondes tout
rond fermeture un moment où elle arrive
à 13 secondes à 13 semaines avec du
stock
[Rires]
voilà c'est terminé merci à l'apparation
de pib je m'appelle quoi ça c'est quoi
un criquet à la fin de l'an dernier
ils sont très forts les bétonneurs
attendez attendez ça va jouer à
l'attention comme vous êtes égalité
attention si vous finissez à la photo
merci de forme il est très fort dans mes
bras
aujourd'hui tu exceptionnel
sans rien
jean michel maire
[Applaudissements]
après quand même la coopérative 6,6 kg
benjamin nous fait pas honte à nos
[Musique]
vaches 6 kg benoît si ça roule bien pour
l'instant ça roule bien
bravo on arrive à droite dylan 23 ans
vingt trois ans du luxembourg votants
pourtant tous vrais boutons en moins
bonjour attention attention pardon
pardon au soleil parce que je suis
important pour la ménagère
les copeaux cet argent tennis
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon j'ai mal
c'est important pour toutes les
personnes âgées qui nous regarde maman
je suis passé à l'attention
[Applaudissements]
là j'ai pu la regarder
rabat s'est bien battu mais benji
d'amour